we're having a baby in three weeks we
will no longer be covered by our health
insurer you want me to be a delivery guy
want you to be anything if it pays
insurance by Tuesday Jason Biggs and
Jenny Mollen say their new comedy
Amateur Night is full of parallels for
one they play a couple in the movie just
like they are in real life I recently
sat down with the actors who revealed
why they were initially hesitant to mix
business with pleasure
we're married first and we want to we
don't want to do anything I can possibly
jeopardize that there are plenty of
other things that are gonna try to bring
us down as a couple but acting won't be
one of them how do you prioritize your
marriage when you're so busy being
parents and and working actors I would
say it is especially hard to have sex
because we have a nanny as well living
in the house and I don't know why for me
I'm just like there's a people here
we're not alone so for instance when
we're on vacation we were those people
like smart car your son's adorable I
know that you guys just moved to New
York is that intentional we don't want
to be raising him in LA are we not
interested in having a Hollywood career
for Syd Biggs I really don't want him to
be in Hollywood at all I definitely
don't want him to be in a career where
he's not in control of his own destiny I
don't I think that I learned the hard
way that that's just like not a fun way
to make a living if acting is one of
those things that he wants to do I'm not
gonna talk him out of that I would
encourage him to just sort of you know
experiment it be more well-rounded baby
number two are you thinking about it
just did want a sibling maybe in the
future I think he's such a great father
to a little girl I would love a little
girl